yeah you thought I wasn't getting review
this engine don't I don't blame you so
now that you've seen how long it takes
me to beat and review a game like
Resident Evil 7 Legend of Zelda breath
is a while to expect that one around
this time 2020 around their Resident
Evil 7 biohazard the Resident Evil 7
biohazard is the newest Resident Evil
game from Capcom and a very much needed
return to form for the Resident Evil
franchise Resident Evil came out in the
mid 90s and it was great age started to
genre survival horror didn't exist
before there were a couple games that
utilize it but it wasn't called survival
horror and Resident Evil came out there
like this is a spearhead this is a
staple we need to name a genre now so
it's the survival horror and they were
survival horror up through about 4 and
then accidentally became action games 4
5 & 6 and it confused people and people
didn't like it as much as they did but
like no one played Resident Evil One and
praised it for being an action-packed
action game and finally realizing this
Capcom was like I think we should go
back to what made Resident Evil 1 great
so now they have with Resident Evil 7
biohazard and Resident Evil 7 he plays a
dude named Ethan whose wife has vanished
she's been gone for a while and he gives
a video from hers like oh my god she's
still alive I need to go find her and
that leads him to a creepy ass mansion
called the Baker estate and now Resident
Evil 7 survival horror and when I say
survival horror I mean it this is
old-school Resident Evil everyone a your
ammo pinching you're like I have a
shotgun shell but I'm going to try to
use my husband as you know you're going
to need those shotgun shells for later
and this really does harken back to
old-school Resident Evil there's some
layouts in designing this manager where
you look at it you're like that's from
Resident Evil 1 like the main room has
the staircase it goes up and around
you're like that from Resident Evil 1
there was a hallway where a staircase
went up and then this door this room's
right around the corner I'm like that's
from Resident Evil 1 the biggest
difference is this game is in first
person you play as Ethan but it's in
first first the other prime chapters of
the Resident Evil series have been in
some form of third-person this is first
verse and although it's obviously a way
for them to push VR because you put on
the VR headset if it's a third person it
doesn't really have the effect the
advantageous thing for this if you get
to really project yourself into the
shoes of Ethan and the other third
person Resident Evil games like in the
first one I played as Jill Valentine or
Chris Redfield
second one I played Leon Kennedy or
Claire Redfield I was the character I
was supposed to be in this one I never
felt like even I felt like me I was in
this place walking around scared out of
my mind if I'm not killing monsters I'm
running from the Baker's the Baker's
holy [ __ ] they're in the Baker estate
the owners of the state are the bakers
and the Baker's are pretty much the
family from Texas Chainsaw Massacre
they're frightening they're creepy they
may be zombified pain worshiping
backwards idiots but there are the
zombified pain worshiping backwards
idiots - the zombify they're not really
zombified pretty much immortal they're
hard to kill you just have to run from
them there was a hallway and I was like
if I was making this game I would have
someone crash through this one right
when I thought that he crashed through
the wall he's like where are you going
boy yes winging this thing at me
thinking of zombified and not zombified
you don't take out zombies in this game
in zombies we're in the 90s because
zombies were getting cool and so they're
just going to make zombies and Resident
Evil and one could argue zombies are
still huge and in the monsters in this
game are not really zombies there are
these black card creep monsters blob
things that look like they killed Tasha
Yar same rules apply though it should a
for the head because that's how you're
going to take them down a disappointment
factor for me is I could have gone for
different monster designs in the game in
terms of the main monsters you run
across in this game you have you know
the black tar monsters then you have
black tar monsters that have a big hook
hand thing that jab you then you have
black tar monsters that are really
skinny and they can jump on the wall
really insane creature design throughout
the entire game with a couple of very
intelligent in there and just like
old-school Resident Evil fashion the
plot is really unfolded through vials
that you find pictures that you find
they're these VHS tapes you pop in a VHS
tape and then you play what's in the VHS
a I thought that was a really cool way
of filling in the gap of story like oh
that happened before there's any text
right kids
VHS tape ask your parents and you do run
into what I ran into a new old Resident
Evil game so I'm not even going to say
it's a fly it's just a saying is that
it's so survival horror and so ammo
pinching you just like I need to find
Miami do not be conservative with your
psychostimulants bugs there's these
little pills that you take there's
psychostimulants and they will show you
where items are like they'll highlight
the items I chose an item
was a night American seafood walls do
you see the item marker through the
walls rather not like you have Superman
x-ray vision point is it's easier to
find mo with them I didn't use all of
them so hey feel free to use them but
that's what I'm talking about want to
pinch em Oh herb first-aid spray by the
end of the game you have a surplus of a
lot of stuff admittedly I could have
gone a little more balls to the wall
with my shotgun had a lot of shotgun
shells by the end of the game like
grenade launchers bang I never used it
could have used that I got a 44 mag with
some animals oh yeah I'm ready to never
use that it kind of made me laugh
because in Resident Evil 1 to the
old-school Resident Evil games I was
always like threw the ammo in there by
the end I'm like oh I could have used
more ammo this game has some puzzles in
it as Resident Evil was known for I
could have gone for the puzzle to be a
little more involved if you're going to
give me a puzzle give me a hard puzzle
it will make me figure that [ __ ] out
this one's like I know exactly how to oh
there you go puzzle solved kind of feels
like a wasted opportunity in the sense
that I don't think this is for kids
obviously for adults is the Resident
Evil game it's matured bloody and
graphic so she's give us some adult
puzzle and next time expose but really
the star of this game is the atmosphere
and tone when you're going through these
hallways you hear [ __ ] all around yours
like I'm scared out of my mind nothing
has to actually be coming after you for
you to be afraid that something's going
to be coming after you that's the mark
of true horror right there really guys
Resident Evil 7 biohazard is fantastic
and it's important for the Resident Evil
franchise going forward Capcom needs to
know that yes this is what good job this
is where you should keep Resident Evil
let's keep doing this you can make the
next game third person or first person
that doesn't I don't care what I care
about is survival horror versus action
and survival horror is definitely what
Resident Evil should be and that's
definitely what this game is I had a
great time playing this game it's
excellent Resident Evil 7 biohazard is
definitely worth buying at full price
I mean we need to wait for a sale man
just go buy it right guys so Resident
Evil 7 biohazard have you played it what
did you think about it where does it
rank in your Resident Evil hierarchy
whatever you think comment below let me
know thank you for being patient I
really appreciate it I do still play
game
I just time and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]